I guarantee if you invite your
friends over for fish and grits
and you have some
crab in your gravy,
they'll be talking about
that for a little while.
My mother cooked the
best collard greens.
My grandmother cooked
better collard greens.
They were the best cooks I knew.
Because of them,
I ended up really
focusing on the food
in the Southern region.
PRESENTER: And the Beard
Award goes to Mashama Bailey.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
MASHAMA BAILEY: When I
think of Southern food,
I think of Georgia, the
Appalachian Mountains,
and the Gulf.
One of the most
common misconceptions
is that it's unhealthy.
But I'm here because I want
to demystify Southern food.
In this MasterClass, I'm going
to show you the rich layers
of cooking Southern food.
And we're going to focus
on different techniques,
like braising,
smoking, and pickling.
We're going to smoke
the collard greens.
With this technique, you're
introducing the element
of smoke without cooking them.
It smells like summertime
in Waynesboro, Georgia.
You really can't have
gumbo without okra.
For folks who don't like
okra because it's slimy,
try charring it first
and then adding it.
The secret to the
gumbo is the roux.
It not only adds texture,
it also adds flavor.
It just feels like a big,
nutritious bowl of goodness.
Converting an old Greyhound
bus station that was segregated
and cooking at the helm
of it is really special.
I often think about
my grandmothers,
who could not even roam through
a building like that freely.
So there's an obligation.
Being Black in
America, we weren't
able to document our recipes.
So we relied on oral histories
to keep our traditions alive.
And I'm really
embracing my own journey
and applying that to
the classical skills
that I've learned.
Thing that I'm learning now
about cooking Southern food
is that the sky's the limit.
So don't be afraid to explore
your own personal cooking
style.
I'm Mashama Bailey, and
this is my MasterClass.